Hello friend, today you are going to be
zero to hero in AWS Lambda. What is AWS
Lambda? What are their benefits? Why we
call them serverless? I will break
everything down with the real examples,
diagrams, definitions, show you exactly
where, why, and how to use AWS Lambda in
real applications. And yes, this is the
one of the favorite questions in AWS
interviews, especially for developers.
By the end of this video, you can easily
explain this concept to anyone in your
interview or anywhere. So, let's get
started. What is AWS Lambda function?
Have you ever used them in your project?
Very very important question from
interview point of view. Stay with me
till the end and then you can explain
this to anyone with example. Let's
understand with the help of an example.
Suppose you are uh a developer and your
development team has created a web
application in AWS. You have the front
end server built in Angular React.js.
This front end passes the request to the
back end or API server which can be int
net java or node and finally everything
connects to the database. Okay. So this
front end and back end can be in uh
hosted in EC2 instances or hosted in
using the elastic bean stock. So that
doesn't matter okay can be in anything.
Now imagine a user is signing up in your
application like this and during the
sign up the user is uploading a photo or
some any kind of image document.
That image document will be stored in
the Amazon S3 storage like this in AWS
cloud. Okay. It S3 is used to store
mainly the images. Okay. And I will
explain in detail in upcoming question
about the this S3. But uh now you know
it is in short used to store the files
and images of your application. Okay.
Now listen carefully. images are very
large in size and uh or maybe videos
very large in size and large image
require more space in S3 which means
more AWS cost for your company because
you are storing bigger files in S3.
Okay. Now as an AWS developer you uh
come up with a brilliant idea or a
solution to save cost of your company.
you used a service in AWS called AWS
Lambda. You created a lambda uh and
inside that lambda you will write some
code to compress the images. Okay. Now
what happens whenever the image is
uploaded in this Amazon S3 storage
bucket or account or storage
then a trigger will be fired and
automatically your lambda function and
the code inside it will be executed and
will compress the image and then it will
store the image. Getting my point?
Before storing the image, the impage
will be compressed in size by your code
which is written inside the lambda
function.
That means now you need less storage is
required in the S3 storage and your
company cost will be saved and that's a
great job and you will get the employee
of the month award for saving company
cost. So this is a very common use case
and if you will say this in the
interview then interviewer will think
that you have read it somewhere. Okay.
So here is one more example.
Suppose you want that as soon as a user
signs in like this uh a successful
welcome email should be sent to the user
automatically back to him. No manual
thing automatically.
For this also you can write a lambda
function which will be automatically
triggered as soon as a user will sign up
and it will uh the lambda function will
send the welcome email to the user.
That's it. Remember lambda function is
just a piece of code which is running
behind background. Okay.
Now I'm sure you are fully understood
the purpose of AWS Lambda right and here
is the simple easy to remember
definition AWS Lambda is a serverless
compute service that lets you run code
in response to events. When something
will happen then your Lambda function
will be triggered. Okay, some event must
happen to trigger the Lambda function
without managing servers. basically
managing without managing servers. What
is the meaning of this? That I will
explain you in the upcoming question in
detail. Okay. So remember in short
lambda function will only execute when
something will happen and it is a piece
of code. All right. If this is fully
clear to you then write crystal clear in
the comments or chat. that will boost
your confidence and help you to never
forget this concept ever in your life.
Also, this diagram and this definition
in the book will help you in quick
revision for your interviews from the
book later. Okay. Now, in interviews
sometimes they ask one indirect
question. Okay. This is the this is the
first question. Now they will ask why
not just write the lambda function code
directly inside the main application
itself. Lambda function is just a piece
of code. Why not to write inside the
main application this same code and
that's a great question and I will
answer that in the upcoming question.
Before moving forward ask yourself just
one thing. What is the point of learning
AWS if you can't crack the AWS
interviewers? That's why I have created
a complete AWS interview preparation
boot camp for you with three powerful
tools. Number three, 200 plus AWS
interview questions from all the topics
step by step. Even if you are AWS
beginner, still you can learn everything
here. Also, the real scenario- based
questions are covered. Then in this
smart excel you can mark questions
prepared or not prepared and therefore
you can track your interview preparation
progress like this. Second tool is this
PDF book for quick revision just before
your AWS interviews. And first tool is
10 AWS mock interviews to help you
practice just like the real interviews.
Many students have already cracked
interviews with my courses. You can be
the next. Remember, just one missed
question can led to interview rejection.
Why take the chance then? Check out all
the links in the description. If
interested, great. If not, no worries.
Let's move to the next question. Why not
include the AWS Lambda function code
directly inside the main application? So
this is a common interview question
especially for developers. So here is
the lambda use case which I explained
earlier. Now practically yes you can
write the uh same lambda code inside
your main application code but but but
in uh real world projects this creates
some performance and design issues.
For example, if you include a lambda
code of the sending welcome email inside
your main app code, then for every user
request, your main application will take
more time to respond because now it has
more code slightly. Maybe it is a small
code but there is some more code to
execute and that will uh you know make
your main application more heavy because
your application have to do more task.
The request will take more time to
process.
Okay. So if you put some code separate
some logic separate inside the lambda
function then the lambda function runs
independently. Remember independently
that means your main application stays
lightweight focused doing its core job
and the lambda functions runs in the
background independently to do the extra
tasks.
In short, keep only the necessary core
code in the main application and the
task which can be delayed or done
independently
or do it through the lambda functions.
Okay, here is the simple answer. Reason
is because AWS fun lambda runs
independently. It improves the
performance of the main application by
keeping main application lighter, faster
and easier to maintain.
Now you may ask why is lambda
independent?
That is because lambda is serverless
service. What serverless means? That I
will explain in the upcoming question.
What exactly is serverless in AWS? Is it
truly serverless? Now you are going to
master this serverless. So I already
explained this use case of uh AWS Lambda
in the previous question. And the
biggest advantage of Lambda is it is
serverless. Now listen carefully.
Serverless doesn't mean that there are
no servers. Lambda functions runs on
some AWS server only. But it is called
serverless means because you do not have
to manage that server that server on
which lambda function is running. Okay.
You will pay for only for how many times
your lambda function is executed not for
the server up time. Getting my point? So
you do not have to worry about anything
about that server like setting it up,
maintaining or anything. And also
remember that your main application
might be running on EC2 or beantock. Uh
but lambda functions run separately and
independently on some separate server
which you do not have to manage. Okay.
So now you may ask what is the advantage
of being serverless. So in AWS this
lambda case lambda function allows you
to separate or decouple some piece of
logic from your main application which
you already know and that is the benefit
of the serverless. It's a big benefit.
Okay. So let me give you an example. See
nowadays everything is moving towards
decoupling and loose coupling. For
example, earlier we have that big
monolithic applications where front end,
back end, logic, HTML, Java, JavaScript,
everything was inside one big
application, right? And we call them
monolithic applications. Now we are
moving moving towards microervices.
a small small piece of independent
services independent which are loosely
coupled which are not dependent on each
other.
So that is the benefit of serverless
being independent. So because as
compared to a big tightly coupled
application a monolithic application
where you will do one change and you
have to test all the application big
application that's a great risk. So
these small small services are important
and AWS Lambda will help you for doing
the same for decoupling the logic from
your main app. Okay.
Whatever logic can be run independently
like uh image compression, email
notification, data cleanup, you can put
that code inside lambda. So that is the
main reason behind the existence of the
AWS lambda and the same is the
importance of uh serverless and
independent services and same for
microservices.
All clear? Now here is the simple short
answer. Serverless in Azure means
running code without managing the
server. And the second part is it truly
serverless? No, it's not. servers still
exist but you don't manage them. Okay,
so that is the answer. Now you will ask
AWS Lambda is triggered by events,
right? So what are those triggers?
What kind what type of are of those
triggers and that I will explain you in
the upcoming question.
Great job my friend. Most will just talk
but the way you finishing the things
shows your dedication and towards your
goal. Now if you understand this lambda
then there are some more related
concepts like SNS, SQS, DLQ that I have
explained in my complete AWS interview
boot camp.
Many of my students have already used my
courses to crack their interviews. Now,
if you don't want to miss a single
question for your next interview, then
check out the boot camp and book link in
the description below.